si uno mira las estadísticas americanas
más del 50% de la población estuvo de
acuerdo con la guerra igual más del 50%
está de acuerdo con la retirada en este
momento en lo que no coinciden es en la
manera en que se retiró eeuu de la
guerra apresurada sin orden dejando muy
mal a los a las tropas americanas allá
ahí se dividen se dividen más o menos en
tres hay sorprendentemente cerca una
treinta por ciento que dice lo hicimos
bien y nos salimos bien no hay salida
decorosa una guerra hay otro que dice lo
hicimos okey como ediciones yo lo
hicimos medianamente bien y otros que
dicen lo hicimos mal pero eso sólo
hablando la retirada la guerra para
todos coinciden en que había que hacerla
era necesario y había que buscar aliados
incómodos como hablaban ahorita de
arabia saudita para esta guerra o como
nos contaban antes de pakistán son
aliados que fueron aliados de eeuu en la
guerra contra el terrorismo a
regañadientes por cuestiones del
petróleo por cuestiones de seguridad en
el tema de pakistán ayuda a militar
porque no podían quedar mal frente al
mundo y decir entendemos lo que están
haciendo los talibanes marque bien
muchos de ellos son paquistanís vienen
de la etnia pastún que es originalmente
paquistaní
entonces la guerra había que hacerla y
eeuu lo entiende así se demoraron mucho
en salirse no hay salida decorosa nunca
en una guerra y hoy hay que ver qué va a
pasar con estos aliados incómodos
durante la guerra pero que siguen siendo
aliados de eeuu en la zona y ver qué va
a pasar ya vimos pakistán hay que ver el
tema arabia saudita recordemos que al
qaeda e isis de alguna manera son
sunitas y arabia saudita están liderando
en el mundo del medio oriente una
cruzada sunita en donde como bien nos
decían antes en teherán hay otra visión
del mundo árabe y yo creo que eso es
algo que tenemos que tener en mente
ahora que eeuu se retira a la zona
eeuu muy buenos para la estrategia
militar muy buenos para invadir pero no
pensaron detenidamente en cómo
desarrollar un país y probablemente ahí
está una de las razones por las cuales
se tardó tanto eeuu en salir de
afganistán y en salir también de irak
qué faltó para poder realmente ayudar a
esos países como lo dijeron tantas veces
en los discursos los presidentes
estadounidenses construir estados muy
difícil y sobre todo en zonas distintas
a nuestra cultura occidental si yo
pudiera hablar antes hablaría de somalia
también cuando llegó el presidente
clinton y había una operación pequeña en
somalia para distribuir alimentos
clinton dijo aquí hay que construir
estado para que la gente no vuelva a
pasar por una crisis humanitaria y viene
toda esta historia de los helicópteros
que se caen y la guerra en somalia lo
mismo podemos hablar de irak cuando eeuu
interviene con esta excusa de las armas
de destrucción masiva llega y
efectivamente hussein en un mes estaba
perdido pero nunca entendieron lo que
era el mundo iraquí desbandaron al
ejército y de alguna manera sentaron las
semillas para isis a eeuu le falta
entender que la cultura americana la
idea de democracia jeffersoniana de
washington no funciona en el medio
oriente que hay que mirar que entienden
ellos por democracia que hay temas
culturales como él de género que a
nosotros nos parece es aberrante pero
resulta que es que esos sean los abuelos
los tatarabuelos y los tíos de quienes
están hoy en el poder hay que mirar el
tema cultural la democracia no es una
camiseta talla única para todo el mundo
hay diferentes tallas hay diferentes
cuerpos y a eeuu la falta de aprender
eso en sus múltiples intervenciones
bueno yo sobre el tema de género solo le
diría que precisamente faltó ese
abordaje con ese enfoque porque así lo
hayan hecho los abuelos los tatarabuelos
y tantos en esa aberrante hay que
revisarlo hay que realmente es aberrante
y rápidamente antes de que lleguemos a
nuestro siguiente momento solemne de la
mañana que será el tercer minuto de
silencio cambio el enfoque no con estos
veinte años de guerra pasamos de la
guerra preventiva a las guerras próximo
estamos hablando de guerras por el
bloque está pasando en yemen pero no
solo cambio la guerra sino cambio el
formato la guerra como bien lo sea
cristóbal hoy hablamos de guerras
híbridas personas sentadas en cuartos
oscuros en eeuu manejando drones que
realmente están es
ocasionando un daño en las antípodas al
otro lado del mundo este concepto las
guerras híbridas guerras cibernéticas
hackers va a ser el modelo dominante de
las guerras durante por lo menos la
próxima década y eso va a cambiar la
psiquis del soldado va a cambiar la
manera en que escogemos a los enemigos
en que peleamos la guerra pero
posiblemente no la manera en que
terminemos las guerras siempre va a
quedar algo inconcluso y darle cierre a
esta violencia de las guerras de los
ataques terroristas es muy complicado
también va a cambiar el enemigo si ya no
estamos peleando contra este terrorista
conocido contra quien estamos peleando
cuál va a ser este enemigo va a seguir
siendo los grupos terroristas cómo lo
vamos a justificar y cómo vamos a
pelearla ese es la pregunta para los
próximos años y la próxima década sobre
todo que en dos décadas hoy todavía no
se sabe cómo se tiene que combatir el
terrorismo no se ha logrado
efectivamente erradicar el terrorismo
que fue la gran promesa que hizo bush en
su momento cuando lanzó la guerra contra
afganistán no yo creo que el amor por el
contrario está más en la mira de
nosotros de los medios de todo el mundo
ha aumentado el terrorismo en esta zona
y si bien se acabó con bin laden con
baghdatis el jefe y si se después hace
unos tres años pero no hemos logrado
acabar con el terrorismo es una guerra
desequilibrada no es una guerra en la
que uno tiene un contrincante definido
unas líneas de batalla es una guerra que
cambia todos los días cambian las armas
cambian las víctimas y cambia la manera
de hacerse y eso es muy complicado
cuando queremos acabar con ello